we have to because it's a cool paper
talk about dopamine oh yeah okay so I
can hear we were gonna we were gonna I
was gonna give you a quick summary
here's a quick summary of what's the
title of the paper I I think we called
it a distributional distributional code
for value in dopamine based
reinforcement learning yes so that's
another project that grew out of pure AI
research a number of people that deep
mind and a few other places had started
working on a new version of
reinforcement learning it would the
which was defined by taking something in
traditional reinforcement learning and
just tweaking it so the thing that they
took from traditional reinforcement
learning was a value signal so that the
at the center of reinforcement learning
at least most algorithms is some
representation of how well things are
going your expected cumulative future
reward and that's usually represented as
a single number so if you imagine a
gambler and a casino and the gamblers
thinking well I have this probability of
winning such and such an amount of money
and I have this probability of losing
such and such an amount of money the
that situation would be represented as a
single number which is like the expected
the the weighted average of all those
outcomes and this new form of
reinforcement learning said well what if
we what if we generalize that to
distributional representation so now we
think of the gambler as literally
thinking well there's this probability
that I'll win this amount of money and
there's this probability that I'll lose
that amount of money and we don't reduce
that to a single number and it had been
observed through experiments through you
know just trying this out that that rep
that kind of distributional
representation really accelerated
reinforcement learning and led to better
policies what's your intuition about so
we're talking about rewards yeah so
what's the intuition why that is why
what is it well it's it's kind of a
surprising historical note at least
surprise me when I learned it that this
had been tried out you know kind of
ristic way people thought well gee what
would happen if we tried and then it had
this empirically it had this striking
effect and it was only then that people
started thinking well gee why wait why
wait why why is this working and and
that's led to a series of studies just
trying to figure out why it works it
which is ongoing but one thing that's
already clear from that research is that
one reason that it helps is that it
drives richer representation learning so
if you imagine imagine two situations
that have the same expected value that
the same kind of weighted average value
standard deep reinforcement learning
algorithms are going to take those two
situations and kind of in terms of the
way they're represented internally then
the next squeeze them together because
the the thing that you're trying to
represent which is their expected value
is the same so all the way through the
system things are gonna be mushed
together but what if instead of those
two situations actually have different
value distributions they have the same
average value but they have different
distributions of value in that situation
distributional learning will will
maintain the distinction between these
two things so to make a long story short
distribution of learning can keep things
separate in the internal representation
that might otherwise be conflated or
squished together and maintaining those
distinctions can be useful in in when
the system is now faced with some other
task where the distinction is important
if we look at the optimistic and
pessimistic dopamine neurons so first of
all what is dopamine our eyes this why
is this at all useful to to think about
in the artificial intelligence sense but
what do we know about dopamine in the
human brain what is what is it why is he
useful why is it interesting what does
it have to do with the prefrontal cortex
and learning in general yeah so well
there's this hint this is also some a
case where there is a huge amount of
detail and debate but
one one one currently prevailing idea is
that the function of this
neurotransmitter dopamine resembles a
particular component of standard
reinforcement learning algorithms which
is called the reward prediction error so
I was talking a moment ago about these
value representations how do you learn
them how do you update them based on
experience well if you if you made some
prediction about a future reward and
then you get more reward than you were
expecting then probably retrospectively
you want to go back and increase the
value representation that you attached
to the that earlier situation if you got
less reward than you were expecting
you should probably decrement that
estimate and that's the process of
temporal difference exactly this is the
central mechanism of temporal difference
learning which is one of several kind of
you know kind of back the sort of the
backbone of our armamentarium in in RL
and it was this connection between the
word prediction error and dopamine was
was made you know in the in the 1990s
and there's been a huge amount of
research that you know seems to back it
up dopamine made to be doing other
things but this is clearly at least
roughly one of the things that it's
doing but the usual idea was that
dopamine was representing these reward
prediction errors again in this like
kind of single number way that
representing your surprise you know with
a single number and in distribution
alrea not learning this this kind of new
elaboration of the standard approach
it's not only the value the value
function that's represented as a single
number it's also the reward prediction
error and so what happened was that will
Dabney one of my collaborators who was
one of the first people to work on
distributional temporal difference
learning talked to a guy in my group
will Chris Nelson who's a computational
neuroscientist and said gee you know is
it possible that dopamine might be doing
something like this distributional
coding thing
and they started looking at what was in
the literature and then they brought me
in we started talking to now a cheetah
and we came up some with some specific
predictions about you know if the brain
is using this kind of distributional
coding then in the tasks that now has
studied you should see this this this
and this and that's where the paper came
from we kind of enumerated a set of
predictions all of which ended up being
fairly clearly confirmed and all of
which leads to at least some initial
indication that the brain might be doing
something like this distributional
coding that dopamine might be
representing surprise signals in a way
that is not just collapsing everything
to a single number but instead it's kind
of respecting the the variety of future
outcomes if that makes sense so yeah so
that's route showing suggesting possibly
that dopamine has a really interesting
representation scheme for for in in the
human brain for its reward signal
exactly that's fascinating
it's just that's another beautiful
example of AI revealing something nice
about neuroscience potentially
suggesting possibilities well you never
know so the minute you published paper
like that the next thing you think is I
hope that replicates like I hope I hope
we see that same thing in other datasets
but of course several labs now are doing
the follow-up experiment so we'll know
soon that it has been it has been a lot
of fun for us to you know to take these
ideas from AI and kind of bring them
into neuroscience and and you know see
how far we can go
you